[Music]
andrea starts off this hour in dallas
texas hey andrea welcome to the ramsay
show
oh dave it's good to talk to you again
you too thank you for having me on your
show well thank you um
i don't know you probably i don't know
if you remember i actually met you back
in 2019 at your studio my husband and i
stopped by and i i i'm a balloon artist
i made a bunch of balloons for your
grandkids oh thank you thank you i'm
darling i'm sorry i met so many people i
can't remember my name so but i'm glad
you're here how can we help
okay i was hoping you could help me with
a little disagreement i'm having with my
husband um
we've been married 10 years and i um
have listened to you longer and got him
on to the uh
the total money makeover and we followed
you and we're able to get debt free good
and
we like it he likes it a lot
and but now we are having
our second baby
due in november
and he's having to work from home and
i'm nesting
and we feel like it's time to move up in
house and we have a little bit of a
disagreement i feel like i found like
the ideal dream house and he feels like
it's too much
and
it would it would cause us to have a
mortgage again for a little while and he
just he just doesn't want to do that
and i'm just like
don't feel like i want to settle when
we're going to be in the house hopefully
a long time
so
that's okay so what is your current home
worth
we are hoping after realtor fees that we
can get about three hundred thousand
dollars out of it um and what would the
other house cost
the other house that we're looking at
um our realtor thinks we could get it if
we made an offer for 4.95
so a move of 200 000 do you have any
money saved above the 300
we do we've got our emergency fund of 16
grand which we're not going to touch
correct and then in other various
accounts we've managed to save up about
a little over a hundred grand okay so
you're only a hundred thousand dollars
in disagreement
basically yeah if you had another 100k
would he be okay with the 500 000 house
he would be thrilled with it his thing
is like so some of these things it's not
too much house it's no debt that he
wants me
right it's not too much house it's not
the no debt he says this house is fancy
it's a want it's not a need we shouldn't
go into debt for a want okay and um
okay i i
i got it i got it and so what's your
household income
so
2021 we did a combined 101 thousand how
quickly can you save a hundred grand
i don't know
um
we
i mean if we
less than three years probably
two to three years two and a half years
maybe two to three years
maybe maybe no definitely projected to
do
definitely
if you had to do it to save your life
you could save a hundred grand in two
years but three you could definitely do
it
okay could you be living on beans and
rice again in order to hit this goal to
do two years
three years you can definitely do it
okay
or you can pick up do you have anything
else you can sell
not nothing that's like worth much i
mean
you got expensive cars
no they're they're used cars and they
are
paid off and they're
you know kind of old okay they're not
expensive okay what about going to a 400
000 house you pay cash for it
have you looked into what that would
look like
we
we've um
we're still looking and keeping our eyes
open we haven't ruled it out
um
okay so here's the deal
what we're really arguing about is not
whether you have too much house if i'm
understanding your outline what you're
really arguing about is the hundred is
whether we go in debt or not
right and your husband's going i finally
got free
i can't walk willingly into another bear
trap
i can't do it i can't i can't swallow
the pill as much as i love you as much
as i want you to have what you want i
just can't go back there it makes me
throw up into my mouth
right and then part of me is also like
inflation is going up and what if i buy
too much house and then like
the country's going crazy and then i
can't like be no you don't have to worry
about that you don't worry about that
what you've got to worry about is what
you can control
your bottom line is you guys are arguing
about a hundred grand and two to three
years
that's what you're arguing about you're
not really arguing about whether to move
if moving is valid whether the 500 000
house is too big a house
uh whether
we're really not arguing about any of
those things we're just a hundred grand
short of doing what you want to do and
you're willing to go in debt and he's
not
correct that's what it comes down to
and so once you quantify it that way it
gives you some real good
points for discussion um
i don't think either one of you are in
the stupid zone with this
if you took out a little mortgage and
paid it off real fast it doesn't violate
our guidelines
but i've got to personally agree with
your husband once i got out of debt you
weren't going to drag me back in kicking
screaming under any circumstances there
wasn't anything sharon wanted bad enough
for me to do that or i wanted bad enough
for me to do that ever
and i was actually more likely to want
something than she was
but you couldn't get me to do it again
so i kind of understand where your
husband's coming from i don't think
george and i have an answer for there's
no one right or wrong here you guys have
to get on the same page whatever you do
going forward and i don't think you're
buying this house unless you both come
into agreement that's for sure